okay we're gonna get to the serious part
of the night but I got to say
congratulations as always thank you so
much joy to be here particularly
representing the little eyes in big
little lies getting to that serious part
is such strong female cast do you think
it is even more special that the
nominations are happening tonight on a
night like tonight I mean for us this
has been such a passion project and it's
about what we did in terms of committing
to each other and being able to get get
this made and create roles for women and
our next series will be now that's
amazing I know that your kids are so
young but what would you say to your
daughter about what is going on today in
the world
they're pretty aware already you know
they're they're very much about
advocating for women's rights and what
they want to do and having opportunities
my my mother was a feminist when I was
growing up but you know this is also
about all of us working together to make
the world a safer better place for all
of us as dad what do you say just well
hopefully you know Nick and I are living
our morals and the way we see the world
and the girls see that they were also
fortunate I think to have the
grandmothers they do to be able to watch
them and see where how they lives so
you've been very instrumental in tonight
and women power
how did like the the Inklings of this
all start well I mean I think it started
way earlier than this
we've had a whole seismic shift in terms
of what's happening and people speaking
out and I think the statement is very
much about there's an outcry right now
and what are those conversations are
instigating change you and you and is so
true you and race events so it's like I
mean for us right now this is about big
little eyes this is about celebrating
what we did for some I mean it took a
number of years to get this project made
and to have had the fans and the
audience react in the way that they have
to - crazy right will a second series
literally because of the audience's
desire we went oh my gosh we've got to
scramble and try and get this together
if we want you to do a season two and we
all kind of put down put our heads
together and when yeah let's try to do
it but that was because of the audiences
and the critical response to this show I
think I was embarrassingly begging you
last or ceremony so we went okay let's
do it and hopefully we'll create more
opportunities for women I mean I'm going
back to work on Tuesday with a female
director so there's also a female GP a
first assistant director who's female so
in that sense you know that's I'm trying
to do my beer